the president and co-founder of the
restaurant opportunities centers United
in the director of the food Labor
Research Center at UC Berkeley please
welcome Saru Jayaraman okay you were so
great the first time we have you back
thank you and more relevant than ever
some of the things you're talking about
you've always been a great Tribune for
the restaurant workers of America let's
first before we get into the connection
to the harassment news that around let's
talk about tips because this is very
relevant to a country that's always
debating minimum wage this is one of
those areas where America pretty unique
right that we still do it by tips
we're so unique because actually tipping
originated in feudal Europe it was like
aristocrats giving something to serfs
and vassals when it first came to the
States
rich Americans brought it and actually
it was around the time of slavery around
emancipation and the restaurant industry
at that time demanded the right to hire
newly freed slaves not pay them anything
and let them live on customer tips and
so the idea of a nothing wage then zero
now $2.00 comes from slavery comes from
the idea that mostly black workers could
earn nothing and live on tips and now we
hear we are 150 years later with a
minimum wage of $2.13 an hour and
millions of women across America and
living on tips yes and it's an industry
we're like 112 people in the country
went out of eleven of people right now
it's almost 13 million workers sounding
yeah and and tell us why it is connected
to harassment when and if there was not
a tipping system that situation would
get better you know right now 70% of the
millions of women a millions of people
across America who live on tips who
worked on the tip minimum wage of two
and three and four dollars an hour 70%
of them are women and they live you know
working at IHOP and Applebee's and Olive
Garden and their median wage including
tips is about nine bucks an hour they
suffer from three times the poverty rate
of the rest of the US workforce but
worst of all they are having to put up
with anything and everything from
customers no matter how they touch them
or treat them or talk to them because
that's where their income is coming from
that's how they're getting paid that's
how they're feeding their families not
from a wage the wage is so low it's
going to taxes so they're having to
murder her the customers are harassing
them but but get this the customers are
harassing them because they live on tips
but because they're living on tips the
manager says dress more sexy show more
cleavage wear tighter clothing in order
to make more money in tips would you
believe when we were doing then the
idiots just think that's an invitation
exactly well not just that the co-worker
who well speaking of Hooters when we put
out this research would you believe the
industry named a new segment a
recognized segment it's called the
breastaurant the breastaurant is a new
segment in the restaurant industry and
it's not just Hooters and Tilted Kilt
and Twin Peaks
it's Olive Garden and Applebee's and
Denny's where women are told show your
breasts but the thing is fully no but
show more breasts we've had from Denny's
who tell us my boss tells me go home and
dress more sexy and shoe more cleat show
more cleavage and come back so you can
make more money in tips [ __ ] up I mean
one of the things that temps I mean I'm
not addressing this situation but more
generally seems to me the point of tips
is it does incentivize good service
right and it's a way in which a customer
can reward good service well we don't do
that with lots of other places where
their service we have scent of ice your
doctor your lawyer your teacher I mean
these are hardworking your pilot many of
them are immigrants by the way really
hard-working immigrants but they're you
know we don't tip anybody else this is
the only industry where the actual
bosses say we shouldn't have to pay our
own workers you the customers should pay
our workers for us you know I've read
recently about a lot of these high-level
chefs who went down in the mid-to thing
and it's interesting it said the theme
that rent through it for me was that
when they weren't harassing they were
screaming yeah you know we'll ask me
about
mean to thing that the first thing the
oysters to my mind is I hate bullies of
any kind and this is a title I'm
wondering what do you what other
industries do you think have not been
talked about yet now we're talking about
restaurants
I mean farm workers face this on the job
Thursday workers face this on the job
pretty much in every industry women who
don't have power and you know you know
what what I haven't heard and I'm gonna
get in trouble for saying it cops
[ __ ] cops man I mean every woman I've
ever known has the story about you know
cuz they have the ultimate power but
when you change that dynamic you know
there are seven states for example in
our industry that got rid of the lower
wage for tipped workers and they have
half the rate of harassment as the 43
states that have this lower wage and
it's because in California which is one
of the seven states a woman doesn't have
to put up with anything and everything
from her boss she gets a full wage from
her boss you know and so she doesn't put
up with everything from the customer and
that's why thanks to the me to moment
New York is about to follow Governor
Cuomo actually just announced thanks to
leadership by women in the legislature
like and restore
that we're actually going to get get rid
of that lower wage for tipped workers in
New York you're gonna keep the tips
absolutely well that's all I'm what so
I'm worried but I think you should be
able to reward your waiter tips a great
job great and so we actually took better
in California than most other states but
the thing is workers women get a wage
get an actual yep it's a little like
making someone jump for it you know it's
a little it's ditched it's it's it can
be it's an anachronism at this point let
this one go I'll give you the I'll give
you the wall everybody wants the tip in
New York they don't care what they do
and they expect you to tip in New York -
that would be fine as long as again
you're walking down so no I have one
thing I have had people love when you
give the money for reason I don't know
what it is